[Musik]
komm auf den Geschmack der Demokratie
die Ukraine hat diese Installationen
mitten in das europäische Viertel in
Brüssel gestellt und genau darum geht es
wie Europa sich schützt und für Europa
die Ukraine schützt wir sind der Frage
nachgegangen wie dieser Krieg Europa und
die NATO verändert okay soll ich
bewaffnet die Ukraine schreiben oder
passt das nicht aufs Plakat
vor gut acht Monaten hat sich die
Ukrainerin Jana noch im
Städtepartnerschaft mit der EU gekümmert
dann kam der Krieg
Waffen für die Ukraine das ist zu lang
hier passen nur wenige Buchstaben drauf
dabei aber okay dann schreibe ich nur
bewaffne ua
die Plakate haben düstere Botschaften in
einer düsteren Welt sie sind für eine
Demonstration vor dem NATO-Hauptquartier
in Brüssel Jana fühlt sich im Krieg und
als eine Soldatin an einem besonderen
Platz
für uns ist die Demonstration wie ein
Fronteinsatz wir wollen dass die
Schrecken des Ukraine Krieges im
Bewusstsein der Mächtigen in Brüssel
bleiben
Putins Krieg hat die ukrainische Jugend
mobilisiert auf der ganzen Welt sie will
ihr Land retten bevor wir Jana auf die
Demonstration vor dem NATO-Hauptquartier
begleiten will sie uns noch diese
kriegsfotos zeigen aufgenommen und
ausgestellt in Brüssel gleich zu Beginn
des Krieges damit keiner Weg sieht
wir können nur hoffen dass jeder
versteht dieser Krieg hört nicht einfach
auf
die russische Zerstörungswut in der
Ukraine spielt sich vor den Toren der EU
ab seitdem Angriff am 24 februar ist der
Krieg in Europa zurück die Freiheit des
Kontinents bedroht
europa muss eine Antwort finden einer
davon Jean Asselborn Außenminister
Luxemburgs seit 18 Jahren bestimmt er
mit er spürt die Angst in den Sitzungen
dass der Krieg ganz Europa im
schlimmsten Fall die ganze Welt erfasst
ich habe an meine Mutter gedacht die am
10 Mai 1940 war sie ein junge Frau und
habe mir das immer erzählt wie die Nazis
in Luxemburg einmarschiert sind
Luxemburg dann beschlagnahmt eigentlich
und ich habe mir gedacht wie viele
Millionen Menschen in der Ukraine jetzt
denselben Gedanken haben
Asselborn gehört der nie wieder
krieggeneration an sie sieht es als ihre
Aufgabe in den nächsten Monaten den
Kampf gegen Russland zu unterstützen wir
haben Mittel um alles zu tun damit
zuerst dieser Krieg sich nicht
ausbreitet und dieser Krieg zu Ende geht
auf den Gängen des Europäischen
Parlaments herrscht nach dem Angriff
aber auch Angst dass Europa nicht
geschlossen der Ukraine hilft das
Russland wie schon bei der Besetzung der
Krim mit seinem Krieg davonkommt vor
allem die baltischen Staaten fürchten
sich wir treffen riotheras einen
estnischen EU-Abgeordneten vier Tage vor
Kriegsausbruch war er an der
russisch-ukrainischen Grenze und
skizzierte danach diesen Schlachtplan
keiner glaubte ihm dass die Russen von
drei Fronten angreifen würden fast alle
haben gesagt das ist unmöglich mit den
mit dem Truppen mit so wenig Soldaten
kann man nicht den drei Fronten anfangen
aber Geschichte hat gezeigt dass die
Russen genau das gemacht haben
Terras war Oberbefehlshaber der
estnischen Armee russische Invasionen
sein Spezialgebiet deshalb weiß er
Moskau sei kurz davor gewesen die
Ukraine zu besiegen
das heißt wie knapp was
ging nur um meinen wichtigen Flughafen
am Rande von Kiew wenn die Russen hätten
das nehmen hätten können dann wäre es
wahrscheinlich anderes gegangen wie sehr
dann Europa aus wenn die Russen Kiew
eingenommen hätten
da hätten wir ein großes Problem
sehr großes Problem
im Frühjahr gingen die Bilder aus der
ukrainischen stadtbuscher um die Welt
sie sollen russische Kriegsverbrechen
zeigen Moskau bestreitet das russische
Soldaten an Folter und Tötungen
beteiligt waren die Verbrechen von
Butcher lösten ein historische Wende in
der EU aus der Schock über die Taten war
der eu-kommissionschefin ins Gesicht
geschrieben
wir haben nach Butcher gesehen dass wir
den Ukrainern helfen müssen auch mit
Waffen nehmen das muss man so nennen das
ist das erste Mal in Europäischen Union
jana ist unterwegs zum
NATO-Hauptquartier auch hier wird der
militärische Widerstand der Ukraine
koordiniert einzelne Länder der Allianz
liefern ihrem Land Panzerhaubitzen und
Raketen sie träumt von mir
wir hoffen eines Tages die ukrainische
Fahne dort zu sehen
ihre Familie ist in der Ukraine ihr
Vater hat sich freiwillig an die Front
gemeldet er hat hier vor kurzem ein Foto
geschickt sie soll sehen dass es ihm gut
geht
wir sind sehr stolz auf ihn
er hat viele chronische Krankheiten
Herzprobleme
unglaublich dass er sich trotzdem
freiwillig gemeldet hat er sagt er macht
es für meinen Bruder und mich doing
it for my brother for me
ohne die täglichen Appelle des
ukrainischen Präsidenten selensky wäre
sein Land wohl schon verloren
unermüdlich fordert er modernere Waffen
vor allem zu Beginn des Krieges
kritisiert er die zögerliche deutsche
Unterstützung
er bewirbt sich für den Beitritt in die
NATO und die Aufnahme in die EU
im Juni dieses Jahres haben wir diesen
diese Entscheidung getroffen dass der
Kandidatenstatus auch das war noch nie
da so schnell ein Land was im Krieg ist
dass wir den Zustand haben das war nur
möglich
dass alle Länder am selben Strang
gezogen haben aber auch weil keiner
sagte auszusehen
Anfang Oktober schlagen russische
Raketen in Kiew ein dies leitet eine
weitere Zeitenwende ein die EU und die
NATO sehen in dem Angriff auf die
Zivilbevölkerung eine neue
Eskalationsstufe der Westen liefert
Raketen Abwehrsysteme die Angst wächst
vor einem nuklearen Krieg bei einer Rede
vor Studenten fragt der
EU-Außenbeauftragte Borell
übrigens wird die Rede übertragen
dann dauert es genau elf Minuten und 41
Sekunden bis sich Borell fließt eine
unverblümte und diplomatische Drohung an
Moskau zu schicken Annie nuklear jeder
nukleare Angriff auf die Ukraine wird
mit einer scharfen Reaktion beantwortet
es wird nicht einen nuklearen
Gegenschlag geben aber die Reaktion wird
so machtvoll militärisch sein dass sie
das russische Militär vernichten wird
das Haus der europäischen Geschichte ist
ein imposantes Gebäude im Herzen
Brüssels ein Ort der an trage schon
glorreichen Momente des Kontinents
erinnert
wir treffen dort Jean-Claude Juncker ein
Urgestein europäischer Politik er war
EU-Kommissionspräsident
ein Ausstellungsstück im Haus der
Geschichte der Friedensnobelpreis für
Europa er droht zu verblassen
den Nachhilfe Generation hatte sich an
friedliche Verhältnisse in Europa
gewohnt trotz Kalten Krieg und trotz der
Bedrohung die aus dem Russen kam waren
die Menschen doch in sich gefestigt weil
sie wussten es gibt die NATO es gibt die
Europäische Union diese alten
Sicherheiten sind weggebrochen
eine Ausstellung erinnert an den
Aufstand in Ungarn Russland als
Bedrohung im Haus der Geschichte werden
vergessene Urängste wach Junker sorgt
sich um Europas Frieden
mich erinnert die Zeit in der wir uns
bewegen an den Ersten Weltkrieg damals
dachte auch alle dieser Krieg findet
nicht statt weil die Fürstenhäuser
miteinander verbandelt und verwandt
waren weil es schon ein gehöriges paar
sein Globalisierung auch gab eben wegen
der Einfluss der Fürstenhäuser und
trotzdem ist das zum Krieg genommen
gekommen und alle dachten dieser Krieg
dauert ein paar Wochen ein paar Monate
und dann wurde das ein kontinentales
Gemetzel größeren Ausmaßes
Jana und ihr Schild sind vor dem
Hauptquartier der NATO angekommen viele
haben hier Väter Söhne Töchter im Krieg
mancher Tote zu beklagen
[Musik]
Liebe und Leben geben wir für unsere
Freiheit heißt es in der ukrainischen
Nationalhymne
sie sind fest dazu entschlossen und sie
verlangen dies auch von Europa
der Ukraine Krieg fordert Europa heraus
es ist wichtiger denn je dass die
Europäische Union mit einer Stimme
spricht
was macht dieser Krieg mit uns und der
Welt alle Teile unserer Doku Reihe
Winter ist coming findet er hier in der
ZDF Mediathek